filière alive bonjour on est en direct
ce vendredi matin pour parler bien sûr
de la situation en ukraine pour
continuer d'en parler avec alexis faire
chaque quinze jours et son adjoint au
pôle actu du figaro on va décrypter
grâce aux cartes réalisées par le
service infographie figaro que ce
conflit et son évolution deux semaines
après son après le début de cette guerre
tout au long de ce live vous n'hésitez
pas bien sûr à poser toutes vos
questions on essaiera d'y répondre au
mieux possible et on va commencer par
une première question alexis sait
comment évolue la situation en général
dans la situation générale sur le plan
militaire donc déjà ça fait deux
semaines est ce qu'on remarque c'est que
le déjà l'ukraine n'est pas tombé donc
ça c'est une première information mine
de rien et la deuxième c'est que depuis
quelques jours la carte générale de
l'ukraine convoi n'a pas tellement
évolué en fait pour une raison simple
c'est que là les les russes sont en fait
dans une stratégie d'encerclement des
principales villes du pays à commencer
par la capitale kiev et donc il ya une
nouvelle ce matin qui est peut-être sur
le plan militaire la nouvelle le
principal du jour c'est qu'en fait vous
aviez déjà l'ouest de la capitale qui
était un peu encerclé par les parlers
russie la fameuse colonne de chars
dont on entend parler depuis une semaine
maintenant mais dorénavant il ya aussi
des chars qui sont arrivés à l'est de la
capitale donc l'encerclement de kiev
n'est pas totale mais il progresse du
point de vue russe on va on va justement
montrer cette cette évolution on pensait
effectivement que là on pouvait penser
effectivement que ça allait aller vite
du côté de kiev le but était d'arriver à
mener une opération éclair finalement ça
n'a pas vraiment été le cas oui en fait
il ya deux sortes de conditions peu
pensé à deux choses cirque y avait une
première stratégie qui visiblement était
la stratégie risquée qui a échoué
c'était de de prendre kiev de manière
extrêmement soudaine avec un assaut
d'hélicoptères par des forces spéciales
a à l'ouest de kehl dans un aéroport qui
paye mais ce domaine et l'idée c'était
vraiment de d'arrivée manière
extrêmement soudaine à kiev directement
pour faire une opération de décapitation
enfin peut-être des captations sens
propre mais de de faire tomber le
gouvernement
et là l'idée c'est que si le
gouvernement ukrainien tombé dès le
premier jour et bals et les soldats
ukrainien n'aurait plus su quoi faire et
finalement il n'aurait pas convaincu
combattu les là et les la guerre aurait
pu se terminer en quelques jours ça
c'est vraiment l'idée d'une opération
éclair au final il n'y a quasiment pas
de combat c'est qu'on serait focalisé
sur la prise de kiev
et la guerre aurait été terminé parce
qu'ils auraient plus de commandement du
pays cette stratégie on l'a on l'a vu à
l'aller échoué et donc là on est dans
une opération dans une guerre d'invasion
beaucoup plus classique cirque on on
avance avec plusieurs fronts et on
essaye d'avancer le plus vite possible
et de ce point de vue là
oui on clairement se répète on
s'attendait à quelque chose de plus
rapide mais parce qu'on va le voir une
résistance ukrainienne qui à la fois
extrêmement forte d'un côté et de
l'autre des faiblesses russes qui sont
aussi très très notable après c'est pas
pour autant que le rapport de forces est
en faveur de l'ukraine le rapport de
forces est toujours en faveur de la
russie et d'ailleurs on le voit bien il
ya clairement une avancée russe même si
elle est beaucoup moins notable ces
derniers jours parce que les opérations
se concentrent sur les villes mais voilà
le rapport de force général dresse en
faveur de la réussite et que prendre des
villes ça ça prend du temps ça prend du
temps c'est d'autres formes de combat
c'est des combats urbains c'est c'est
pas des des combats de chars sur des sur
les grands axes et
le rapport au temps n'est plus le même à
classe folle on l'a vu quand la guerre
d'irak il ya neck se gausser vie qu'en
fait du combat urbain
on calcule michel goya on parle est sûre
on calcule le nombre de de centaines de
mètres pris par jour ça se compte pas en
kilomètres on dizaine de kilomètres
alors que si vous avancez
dans des grands combats où vous pouvez
avancer plusieurs kilomètres par jour
plusieurs des années km là on compte pas
en kilomètres par jour c'est ce qui
s'était passé au début du conflit des
pouvait dire que c'est triste justement
on peut parler peut-être de l'est pour
ça pour le dans le donbass donc ces
régions qui sont qui sont ici on pouvait
aussi s'imaginer que de ce que ça
pourrait aller très vite dans deux dans
cette région là et finalement il ya les
forces russes ont tous deux été bloqué à
ce moment là en fait ce qu'il ya c'est
que ce qu'il faut garder à l'esprit
c'est que là les forces les plus
importantes ukrainienne sur le
territoire ukrainien sont la foi dans
l'est et à qui a fait donc là où les
combats sont les plus rudes c'est
vraiment dans l'est si tu remontes un
peu là la carte principale on le voit il
ya trois points très encore un tout
petit peu voilà il ya tout en sait qu'il
ya de charny yves là c'est une ville qui
depuis le début
est quasiment les les russes n'ont
contourné ils n'arrivent pas à rentrer
dedans c'est une ville qui est
complètement détruite par les
bombardements
pareils a soumis pareil à kharkiv car
kingston important c'est la deuxième
ville du pays à 1 million et demi
d'habitants
et dont le dombass pareil depuis 2014
donc il ya eu la guerre 2014 bassac les
séparatistes les les ukrainiens avait
extrêmement bien
constituée en défense au niveau du
dombass et deux au blast 2 de donetsk
est lougansk mais en ce qui est
intéressant et qu'on commence avons
observé sur la carte c'est que la
stratégie russe ça consiste à faire d
attaque de revers et a créé ce que les
russes appellent des chaudrons des
quotas
finalement pour créer des poches de
résistance ukrainienne qui seront
imprimés coincé et là on en voit ça la
nouvelle a été annoncée hier tient ni
vent en
est complètement cirque les serres que
les forces de rien ils n'ont plus les
moyens d'être ravitaillées ou 2 ou même
de reculer et c'est donc ça crée un
rapport de force qui est différent et
l'a clairement c'est là c'est la
stratégie stratégie russe on voit que
soumis aussi quasiment encerclée est
l'un des grands enjeux ça va être cool
d'encerclement de kharkiv qui est en
cours mais qui n'est pas du tout terminé
et pareil dans le bon bah si on
redescend encore un peu on voit que la
stratégie jury ce n'est pas forcément
d'avancé directement depuis les
territoires séparatistes en orange mais
de prendre par le nord on voit la flèche
et en même temps de prendre part le
soutien ça va être le fond du sud qui
remonte et l'idée c'est de prendre les
forces ukrainienne en tenaille et hélas
il ya un effondrement du fond de la sq
haute et ukrainiens c'est probablement
ça aussi recherche les russes
c'est une sorte de choc frontal mais
même dans le camp pas frontale plutôt
plutôt latéral
si les défense ukrainienne s'effondre à
cet endroit là ça pourrait être un
tournant de la gamme mais encore une
fois rien n'est fait parce qu'il y assez
de résistance ukrainienne c'est agréable
ely d'ely débrouiller c'est d'arriver à
créer des sièges en fait autour des
villes des sièges mais c'est pas que
autour des vitres ça se joue à toutes
les échelles géographiques ça ça joue au
niveau des villes on le voit notamment
on parlera peut-être même la ville le
port de marioupol au sud qui est
absolument stratégique et c'est des
bombardements terrible qu'un hôpital qui
avait été bombardée non ça joue au
niveau des villes mais ça peut se jouer
dans des zones beaucoup plus large de
kazim au niveau régional et sans le voit
en haut notamment un canif vous
n'hésitez pas bien sûr quand on tousse
tousse live à poser vos questions modibo
qui nous dit bonjour christian léon
toussaint qui nous a rejoint aussi
bonjour à lui donc voila vous n'hésitez
pas à poser vos questions justement on
peut parler de ce front du sud aussi se
font du sud qui a lui pour le coût
avancé assez fort en dessous alors il a
avancé à ses formes de fun sachant que
ça se ralentit ses animaux parce qu'elle
prenne effet plus vous avancez un peu
plus vos le front s'élargit en distance
et donc moins vous avez d'hommes a
envoyé pour continuer d'avancer donc ces
derniers jours s'est un peu ralentie
mais de rien le résultat est là c'est
que c'est au sud que les russes
maîtrise le plus vaste territoire étant
donné que c'est aussi laquelle le moins
de défense ukrainienne annonce assez
calme à prendre en compte alors sur le
son du sud pour être très synthétique il
ya trois objectifs majeurs on a un tout
petit peu par l'eia vers l'est contrôlé
les bords de la mer d'azov qu'une mer
quasiment fermée par le détroit de
kertch et créer un corridor terrestre
entre la crimée qui a été annexé par la
russie en 2014 en orange et les
territoires séparatistes
parce que ça crée un lien direct
terrestre avec la russie pour l'instant
il ya qu un lien par un pont au niveau
du détroit de catch donc ça c'est le
premier objectif et on a vu que la
l'encerclement de manip les faits et il
ya une manoeuvre d'encerclement pour
assez classique et les deux territoires
se sont rejoints il ya un 2e axe
symétrique vers l'ouest c'est dire que
maintenant que la mer d'azov est entre
guillemets un lag russe l'autre objectif
c'est d'avancer pour contrôler les bords
de la de la mer noire on peut penser que
c'est un des objectif stratégique de
devenir poutine et on voit très bien
alors là ils ont avancé ils ont pris
personne là où il ya actuellement les
combats les plus importants voile et les
étoiles entre guillemets rouge c'est
nikolay africain
grand port donc l'as nika les riches
n'est pas prise encore mais en revanche
est quasiment encerclée c'est pour la
honte vraiment un point
assez importante ce qui a énormément de
villes qui sont sur le point d'être
complètement cercle est donc mis que
lagaf et si vous continuez ensuite vers
l'ouest vous avez la troisième ville de
dessin la troisième ville du cred qui
est donc au dessin et qui est
extrêmement important on a fait un
reportage d'envoyé spécial sur cette
ville c'est une ville chargée d'histoire
c'est une ville très riche une station
balnéaire c'est une ville
traditionnellement russophone nos même
temps une ville symbole du
multiculturalisme craignent un expert et
c est donc là la question c'est les
russes en approche est ce qu'ils vont
bombarder au dessin
bombardé ou des sas d'une certaine
manière c'est comme l'hypothèse d'un
bombardement massif de kiev ça serait un
fan plus qu'un drame j'ai deux mots
enfin ça serait un espace rethel
vraiment une tragédie et d'ailleurs ça
serait une tragédie on nous dit
peut-être pas c'est aussi pour les
russes étant donnée justement les
arguments c'est louis l'intérieur étant
donné les arguments de de poutine qui
dealent se sont
aussi c'est une partie de notre histoire
le odessa qui avait donc là on est à un
point d'eux
de basculer c'est vrai que si les
ukrainiens père d odessa bien y perdrait
le contrôle de la mer noire voilà ça
n'en joue assez assez important et
troisièmement sur le fond du sud vous
voici qu'est des flèches qui remonte
vers le nord alors là c'est à la fois le
le long du gnac prince est vraiment le
grand fleuve ukrainien c'est le repère
le plus important jeu en film en ukraine
et on voit que ça remonte un homme tombe
pas dans toutes les directions mais
disons qu'il ya l'enjeu de remonter vers
le nord et donc de prendre ans j'avais
dit à mon sandwich les les forces
ukrainienne qui sont vers l'est dans le
but de créer ses chaudrons donc ça c'est
un objectif strictement militaire et
puis on va aussi une flèche qui remonte
de manière assez étrange à partir de
nicolay f on comprend pas pourquoi ils
perçaient extrêmement étroite vers le
nord où vont les russes en fait c'est
très simple si vous prolongez
l'offensive russe vers le nord-ouest à
partir de micola diaf vous avez une
centrale nucléaire
donc c'est probablement l'objectif des
russes il faut savoir que déjà au
nord-est de carson dans la zone déjà
contrôlé par les russes vous avez deux
premières centrales nucléaires dont on a
beaucoup parlé avant dernière voilà qui
est la plus grande centrale
nucléaire de rennes probablement
d'europe il ya six réacteurs nucléaires
celle au nord-ouest et un peu plus petit
mais enfin voilà globalement si si les
re s'emparer de ces deux centrales
nucléaires ils contrôleraient neuf des
quinze acteurs nucléaires en service en
ukraine donc on peut penser que c'est un
des enjeux de cette opération avec tous
les risques que cela fait courir en
termes de sécurité des sites nucléaires
même si pour l'instant n'y a pas eu de
drame heureusement voilà mais l'idée
l'idée dans ce cas c'est effectivement
de contrôle d'électricité du pays ont
contrôlé l'électricité du pays ont fait
de manière générale c'est s'emparer des
sites stratégiques du pays et s'est pas
seulement des styles des sites
militaires c'est aussi des sites civils
très bien on vous parlait tout à l'heure
de la de la mer d'azov et de la mer
noire cc c'est pourquoi c'est important
pour la pour le pouvoir pour l'art qui
de contrôler l'espace maritime dans
cette guerre or il ya plusieurs raisons
déjà pour la mer d'azov je voulais 10 et
désenclaver la crimée y avait aussi le
l'enjeu de l'eau qui était qui était
important après c'est difficile de on
peut identifier des enjeux par exemple
ça pourrait être de dire si les russes
contrôler l'intégralité des côtes
ukrainienne va tout simplement
la mer noire devient un la grue sous un
lac russo turque
mais dire ça oui mais ça dépend de quels
sont les objectifs de poutine s'il veut
vraiment conserver l'ukraine mais c'est
un scénario parmi d'autres en revanche
il est dans une logique de
deux neutralisations sens diplomatique
de l'ukraine ça peut être aussi
important et puis même symboliquement ce
assez c'est assez fort dans l'objectif
aussi des buts de guerre dont parlera
enfin la suite effectivement on à
christian léon toussaint veulent passer
au guichet des six mois qui nous qui
nous disent bonjour mais salut aussi
criante ce qui nous dit après cette
guerre il ya une guerre de soulèvement
des citoyens russes en en russie ça
c'est quelque chose qui est qui qui
compliquait après voir vu les
manifestations qu'on a vu jusque là
c'est très compliqué à prévoir il ya des
manifestations
assez importante et plusieurs milliers
plus de même dix mille arrestations il
ya une loi russe qui est passée
équipe qui condamne comme jusqu'à 15 ans
d'emprisonnement
tout discours alors qualifié de fake
news en russie enfin c'est qu'ils ne
rentrent pas dans la ligne officielle du
du kremlin après savons exactement ce
que pense la population russe c'est
compliqué il est probable que néanmoins
beaucoup de russes sas ça ce sont de
parler les sources qu'on ne m'aime pas
très heureux de
de la guerre même si encore une fois
fttu toujours à rappeler ils peuvent
être contre la guerre
il est par ailleurs
plus ou moins d'accord
avec les critiques que vladimir fait par
vladimir poutine fait par ailleurs
depuis des années sur la question de
l'extension de l'otan sont des enjeux
sécuritaires et même sur la dimension
historique sur le récit historique du
kremlin qui dit que grosso modo
l'ukraine et russe et la vielle rossi et
russes pour former une grande russie
voilà mais ce n'est pas pour ça que les
russes sont favorables à la guerre parce
qu'il voit bien que le rapport coûts
bénéfices ne s'aiment guère pour le
kremlin on voit pas très bien où une
victoire militaire mais à quel prix à
quel prix militaire à quel prix
politique à quel prix économique quel
prix social surtout qu'on le disait au
début du live le le conflit a commencé
depuis deux semaines et on a
l'impression d'un enlisement des forces
russes est ce que l'on peut le allant on
peut dire ce cas en fait il ya il ya
deux risques de forme d'enlisement il ya
déjà le là que la dynamique que l'avancé
des militaires des russes
s'arrête et donc ont une ligne de front
qui se stabiliserait
là on n'y est pas encore mais mais ce
qu'on voit c'est que la
l'avancée des troupes russes n'est pas
aussi rapide que ce qui était prévu et
deuxièmement il ya un enlisement
a posteriori un risque d'enlisement qui
en fait le fait de s'enliser dans les
territoires contrôlés et si vous voulez
dans la guerre d'irak en 2003
elle avait été pillée très rapidement
serre qu'ils avaient conquis les
américains et conquis de l'irak
rapidement mais ensuite il ya une guerre
qui elle a duré vingt où c'est plus de
plus de 10 ans et qui était une fois
qu'on contrôle le terrain on fait
comment pour contrôler et là on n'est
plus dans une guerre conventionnelle de
haute intensité on est dans une guerre
d'insurrection et de contre insurrection
composite a pris une petite guerre est
là bas ont l'expérience montre
l'expérience notamment occidentales
n'ont que ce sont des guerres finalement
les gagne jamais on
on peut pas dire un jour on arrête la
guerre en disant ça y est on a gagné
c'est en fait une sorte de guerre
éternelle tout au bout d'un moment on
finit par partir parce qu'on n'en peut
plus voilà et donc ça c'est un risque
très important pour les russes et
comment ils vont faire pour tenir
quelques villes dix ans et alors ils ont
déjà
conquis certaines villes notamment
personnes militent au paul eh bien on
voit qu'il ya des manifestations
pacifiques contre la présence des
soldats russes comment ils vont faire
pour
tenir dans la durée c'est trop observe
qu'il faut c'est vite ça qu'il faut
mettre des troupes il faut les mettre
les chargés de de tenir les villes
occupées ce sont autant de troupes qu'on
ne met pas sur le front
c'est effectivement la grande question
alors dans les commentaires
christian léon nous dit nous sommes
rentrés dans le sac de l'imprévisible
yogi la question est combien de temps
avant que l'humanité de s'auto détruit
avec ses propres armes on est sur des
questions à ces listes
il ya clairement aujourd'hui c'est assez
frappant une 102 de retour de la
de l'imaginaire nucléaire
un imaginaire de guerre froide oui et
comme c est qu avait plus ou moins
disparu
depuis 1981 c'est aussi une grammaire la
dissuasion nucléaire en entre la rue
entre la russie les états unis et on
voit que là tout d'un coup c'est une
grammaire que les dirigeants
recommence d'utiliser et on n'a plus du
tout l'habitude
et le principe même de la dissuasion
on aurait pu et dû forcément ça crée
donc des peurs est ce qu'on va voir
père magna yens pas par définition il ya
une imprévisibilité ça veut pas dire
qu'on est au
bord de la guerre nucléaire
après par définition dans le cas de la
dissuasion nucléaire on ne peut jamais
évité un fassi on peut jamais exclure un
accident ce live justement que cette
grammaire ne soit plus maîtrisée par les
deux acteurs on à yogi dans les
commentaires qui ne dit que la russie ne
pourra jamais tenir le pays on peut
rappeler effectivement
gigantesque qui est très peuplées en
europe c'est ce qu'on a dit c'est un des
grands enjeux
pour les russes le maintien de l'ordre
dans les territoires occupés
ça pose aussi la question de quels sont
les objectifs militaires de vladimir t
es et avant ça
jusqu'où militairement peut aller bien
possible parce que par ailleurs si la
faut dire les choses clairement on va
vers une guerre qui va durer longtemps
un potentiellement plusieurs plusieurs
mois parce que le pays n'est pas tombé
et donc c'est à dire que s'il faut que
les russes arrivent à
maintenir des on parle de 200 mille deux
cent mille hommes il faut qu'ils
arrivent à mobiliser pendant pendant
plusieurs mois
deux cent mille hommes et qu'il faut que
ça tourne bien lui-même combattants
peuvent pas se battre pendant ton et
semaines on a vu quelques
que certaines troupes étaient revenus à
belgorod justement pour reformer
des belgrade en russie pour reformer des
brigades faut que ça et c'est un énorme
enjeu logistique et puis aussi
psychologique pour les russes et scully
sont prêts à mener une guerre à me dire
mon cher de plusieurs mois où on parle
quand même de deux paires taurus faire
très attention aux chiffres mais les
etats-unis ont dit au moins entre deux
et quatre mille morts en deux semaines
c'est simon énorme les ukrainiens de
noeuds des chiffres encore plus élevés
voilà la
lécher les lire les rues sont 10 500
morts bon ok il ya probablement
plusieurs milliers de morts c'est
absolument considérable
si les combats demeurent des semaines
voire des mois à ce niveau d'intensité y
compris pour le matériel pour les pour
les blindés pour les chars pour les
avions pour les missiles pour les stocks
de munitions
et c'est donc là il ya une alors sachant
que le lay a vraiment une impression que
sur le terrain ça n'avançait plus
ce qui est aussi probable c'est que les
russes aient fait ce qu'on appelle une
pause tactique ça qu'ils sont rendus
compte que leurs manoeuvres depuis le
début
ne fonctionnait pas bien
grosso modo c'est les manoeuvres étaient
pas organiser cirque il y avait d'un
côté
il y avait des troupes qu'avancé par des
chars mais qui n'était pas protégé son
appui aérien sans moyens de
reconnaissance sans infanterie et donc
elle se faisait taper par la dernière
est donc là il y avait un problème de
manoeuvre donc là on commence à voir
selon certains experts des manoeuvres un
peu plus travaillé notamment avec un
usage de drones de reconnaissance enfin
c est donc il est probable que les
russes aient aussi fait une pause pour
se réorganiser parce qu'ils sont rendus
compte que leurs opérations militaires
ne fonctionnait pas
voilà on a une question de du lis qui me
dit pourquoi l'onu d'envoi pas de
casques bleus est ce que ce serait
possible d'enlever des casques bleus il
y a quand même la preuve de l'onu c'est
qu'il sait que c'est qu'il ya un droit
de veto qui était équipé qui est tenu
par là qu'il peut pour des raisons
politiques chez
c'est pas d'un actualité puis on non
c'est pas possible
justement on va parler aussi de la ddt
ont parlé de l'enfant je précise juste
sur ce point en 2014 une fois qu'il y
avait eu un cessez le feu aux accords de
minsk ça c'était pas des casques bleus
mais c'était l'eau à eux y avait une
organisation de sécurité et de
coopération en europe qui est qui
comprend qui inclut la russie il ya un
peu plus en tout cas la cie et il y
avait des observateurs qui vérifier le
respect du cessez le feu n'était pas
parfait mais les observateurs de l'osce
et eux avaient été dépêchées sur le sur
le terrain d'accord on parlait justement
de cet enlisement russe on peut parler
peut-être des conditions météorologiques
qui peuvent jouer aussi alors enlisement
jeu il est trop tôt pour moi même et
risque d'enlisement et leurs pareils
en saas et c'est un moulin qui tourne
dans tous les sens tout les met dans
tous les médias c'est la race petit ça
c'est qu'on se gamelle est un peu
l'histoire militaire de même bien
mondiale
le connaissent bien c'est en fait le
pire dans les campagnes militaires
en ukraine mans aussi
cc - là la neige que la boue c'est à
dire que quand le printemps commence
d'arriver bien le
énormément d'eau enfin la neige fond et
donc du coup là tout se transforme en
boue est donc tout simplement vallée les
chars les véhicules ne peuvent plus
avancer alors néanmoins ya une grande
différence par rapport à la seconde
guerre mondiale c'est pendant la seconde
guerre mondiale dont clara ce petit ça
avait désavantager les allemands
certains moments désavantager les
soviétiques à d'autres
mais la grande différence c'est que je
m'ennuie quand même les routes sont soit
installe t donc de ce point de vue là
les chars peuvent continuer à passer
c'est plus comme ça quand c'était
principalement à 95% des des chemins de
doutait mais c'est un homme un enjeu on
a vu que les mêmes les ukrainiens
joue là-dessus lisons pas remplies
inondées au nord-ouest de kiev ils ont
ouvert les
vannes les vannes entre guillemets de
dunières et il ya des très très grand
espace qu'ils ont complètement inondée
il ya des convois logistiques gauche qui
le goût étaient complètement coincés ils
pouvaient plus passer d'accord grâce
grâce justement à cette manoeuvre
absolument on salue rome qui vient
d'arriver requiem for a dream
yogi alors n'hésitez pas à continuer à
poser vos questions on peut peut-être
parler sur les sur la sur la solitaire
c'est l'ukraine qui a demandé à se faire
livrer des avions des mig ci jouit en
fait elle a demandé c'est assez logique
des avions que ses pilotes
pouvaient utiliser immédiatement parce
que si on leur avait fourni change pas
des f-16
le talk est pilote ukrainien apprennent
à s'en servir
j'espère que la guerre est finie et donc
en fait ça laisse peu de possibilités
leur faut des avions
d'origine soviétique en fait il ya plus
beaucoup d'états en europe qui en ont il
ya là la pologne cas des mig-29 il ya
aussi la slovaquie qu'on a encore
quelques-uns et la bulgarie mais ça ça
pose est alors c'était assez intéressant
c'est que zelensky à a demandé ces
avions il ya une réponse européenne qui
a été immédiatement positive ensuite les
bleus ont les polonais ont dit pourquoi
pas on est tout à fait favorable à cette
idée et ensuite il y en tout il a dit
attention parce que
vous pourriez être accusé de kobe liger
ans et on pourrait vous considérez comme
faisant partie de la guerre alors
qu'officiellement n'est pas en guerre
et en relais d'une centre d'un imbroglio
diplomatique les polonais ont fait
machine arrière ensuite ils ont dit oui
mais on va transférer nos 1029 aux
américains là les américains diboula
laon absolument pas prévenus de la
proposition polonaise nous on n'est pas
d'accord pour accueillir d 1029 les
poser dans une base américaine de l'otan
par exemple einstein on a du mal
également dit non non ne disent pas non
plus les aéroports donc là on est qu'ils
sont coincés à keynes dans le sol sur le
principe ils sont d'accord mais le
prêtre 6 mai à l'essayer en fait une
sorte de ligne rouge qui a été fixé par
vladimir poutine et donc il faut rester
sous la ligne rouge visiblement là on
n'a pas trouvé de moyen pour que les
limites de l'envoi de mig-29 ça soit en
dessous la ligne rouge mais en presque
un intéressant il faut pas non plus
surestimer l'impact qu'auraient ces dix
vingt trente mille 29 qui interviendrait
dans le conflit
ce ne serait pas un game challenger qui
permettrait de changer le cours de la
guerre qui court de la guerre
radicalement la russie est encore en
revanche ce qui pour l'instant est sous
la ligne rouge
c'est toute l'aide militaire qu'on en
voit déjà aux ukrainiens et en fait se
focaliser aussi politiquement sur les
mig 29 ça permet de ne pas parler de
l'aide qui elle arrive en ukraine et qui
est assez efficace et qui pour le dire
rapidement il ya les missiles antichars
les fameux javeline américains et les
missiles anti-aériens stinger qui sont
en fait c'est pas des armements lourds
comme comme déployé des avions de chasse
ses demis il comporte à l'épaule
mais en revanche qu'on a un impact sur
le terrain qui est quand même assez
puissant d'autant que les ukrainiens
savent les utiliser parce qu'elle est
déjà venu notamment sont fournis à
l'ukraine depuis un certain nombre
d'années et donc c'est encore une fois
il n'ya pas d'art miracle ça peut pas
changer du tout au tout le rapport de
force mais mes revanche
ça déstabilise énormément les russes on
a vu un nombre de chars de blindés
russes complètement calciné avec la
tourelle des chars qui avait
complètement disparu
des rues
des cages leur tourelle pour les
protéger suffit pas donc ça c'est un
vrai impact et cal avantage
diplomatiquement
d'être moins moins fort que d'envoyer
des
mig-29 de toi qui est aussi un enjeu
technique c'est que les mig 29 polonais
ont probablement été organisées cercle
avant les filets aux
polonais et aux ukrainiens il faudrait
peut-être enlevé quelques petits
réglages pour objet de nous voilà dans
l'est dans les commentaires ça débat
énormément en ce moment sur la guerre de
l'information qui est qui ce qui suit
qui se joue est justement sur le sur
l'usagé des réseaux sociaux dans cette
guerre c'est quelque chose qui est assez
intéressant puisque à ces nouveaux tout
on l'a déjà vu dans des conflits
précédents mais là c'est la première
fois qu'on est dans une dans un conflit
comme celui-là on est trois points déjà
il ya une évidence et que l'ukraine a
vraiment gagné la guerre de
l'information
en tout cas
écoutez occidental les russes n'arrive
pas à faire passer un contre-discours
qui soit crédible ou qui qui arriva à
toucher vraiment les opinions publiques
après ils verrouillent leur propre
opinion publique
avec plus ou moins de succès ça c'est ce
qu'on disait tout à l'heure c'est
difficile à estimer en revanche les
ukrainiens sont vraiment extrêmement
fort pour là c'est de la sorte de guerre
psychologique de guerre médiatique
internationale et qui passe énormément
par les réseaux sociaux aussi accès
c'est pas seulement des autorités
installées à kiev qui transmettre des
images les l'information c'est vraiment
tous les ukrainiens qui partagent des
photos des vidéos sur les réseaux
sociaux ça je pense que là dessus on est
tous d'accord le deuxième point c'est
commence à créer un billet c'est à dire
qu'on a lorsqu'on a publié un interview
très intéressante avec
olivier ken sur ce sujet ça craint biais
cerqueux on a tendance peut-être à
surestimer les petites victoires
tactiques de l'ukraine
mais en revanche comme on a très peu
d'informations côté russe est ce qu'on a
du coup une vision relativement entre
guillemets objectifs du conflit c'est
pas certain et comme c'est olivier kempf
le raconte très bien comme on a
envie que david gagné contre goliath
toutes les petites victoires une
chrétienne on a peut-être tendance à
l'est est surmédiatisée lé sommet et
isea et a surtout augmenté
excessivement leur leur impact réel sur
le sur le cours des choses voilà
effectivement et le troisième - ça c'est
un point pourtant caisse souligné par un
certain nombre d'officiers français qui
observe la manière dont le conflit est
allé raconter je vous disais que
beaucoup de civils poster des vidéos et
notamment ce qu'on voit pas tellement à
la dans une guerre télévisuelle seigneur
fait part des médias sur les réseaux
sociaux on va énormément de vidéo de
soldats russes tués mais identifiables
les ukrainiens utilise beaucoup ça
probablement pour affaiblir le moral des
rues c'est à dire les russes tout d'un
coup pour aient accès aux réseaux
sociaux verrez ces corps de jeunes
soldats parfois reconnaîtrez les
familles pour elle reconnaître c'est
absolument terrible alors c'est la
propagande de guerre on peut dire c'est
de bonne guerre mais attention il ya des
textes internet internationaux sur la
convention de genève on n'a pas le droit
de filmer des des corps de soldats on
n'a même pas le droit de filmer ou de
photographier ou de mettre en scène des
prisonniers de guerre sans leur
autorisation or ce qu'on voit depuis le
début de la guerre
c'est vraiment une surexposition de ça
c'est extrêmement violent et ça crée
parfois des sentiments peu détestable
sur réseaux sociaux
c'est quand même d'aider des gens qui
meurent et parfois on se dit ouh là il
ya quelque chose de malsain là-dedans
faut pas vraiment faire attention à ça
aussi l'article dont tu parlais ici
l'ukraine sous-estiment dont la
puissance de la relance à cause de la
guerre de l'information donc à retrouver
sur le site du figaro bien évidemment
effectivement ces photos de 2,2 de deux
soldats russes et parce que aussi la
russie a une stratégie de ne communiquer
de ne pas du tout communiquer sur ses
pertes absolument puisqu'elle ne parle
pas de guerre c'est une opération
militaire spéciale hier la vente le
ministre des affaires étrangères
a même expliqué qu'il n'y avait que la
russie n'allait pas un vire d'autres
pays et que d'ailleurs elle n'avait pas
enrayé l'ukraine alors c'est quand même
difficile à croire mais mais en tout cas
c'est là la stratégie la stratégie russe
sur les médias russes officiels
notamment la télévision publique c'est
un mélange c est quand même temps on dit
qu a pas de guerre handicap à deux morts
on dernier tout mais en même temps on
galvanise
le peuple russe autour de la légitimité
de cette intervention de des nazis
compris le pouvoir à kiev et c'est à
nous donc c'est un peu les deux à la
fois c'est étonnant est en tout cas on a
va dire petit pendant très longtemps et
étaient calmes assez fort pendant toutes
ces dernières années pour arriver à
maîtriser le la narration de ces
opérations étrangères qu'elles soient
diplomatiques ou militaires et même
auprès des occidentaux c'est qu'il
arrivait à appuyer les cff ça faisait
marly il faisait remarquer aux
occidentaux qui avaient
des doubles standards qu'on reprochait
des choses à certains pays mais à ne pas
nous même et c est là le d'ailleurs leur
petit nom n'entend quasiment pas on n'a
pas l'impression qu'ils aient la main
sur la narration de ce conflit
effectivement on n'avait jamais vu aussi
une question sur les i sur les couloirs
humanitaires qui ont qui ont été mis en
place que que veut dire petit a voulu
mettre en place depuis le début de
semaine ces couloirs humanitaires à quoi
ils servent est ce que c'est vraiment le
but recherché on va dire
déjà le contexte faut bien comprendre
que là donc on est entré dans des
combats urbains qui peuvent être
vraiment terriblement meurtriers
pour rappel la dernière grande guerre
qui a vu en europe les guerres
d'ex-yougoslavie
c'était plus de cent mille morts alors
qu'on était sur un territoire plus petit
donc faut avoir ces ordres de grandeur
là il ya deux millions et demi de
réfugiés quand d'ores et déjà quitté
l'ukraine ya probablement autant qu'ils
sont déplacés à l'intérieur du
territoire ukrainien
l'onu estime qu'il pourrait y avoir
jusqu'à 7 millions de réfugiés il ya la
moitié des habitants de kiev qui ont
déjà quitté la capitale on voit des
bombardements qui ont rasé
des immeubles qui sont des immeubles
d'habitation on a vu des frappes contre
un hôpital mariupol donc c'est un enjeu
humanitaire qui est absolument essentiel
donc
les pour pourquoi est ce que les
occidentaux et les ukrainiens
ont un doute sur les sur les se méfie de
le dollar et aux rigoureuses sur les les
couleurs immunitaire c'est l'expérience
notamment l'expérience syrienne ça
pourrait être si vous faites partir
les civils des villes et c'est bien
normal on pour les protéger en revanche
après les bombardements
ça peut légitimer une paire une
augmentation des combats puisque les
civils ont leur visite jusqu'à lembi que
ligne analyse sauf qu'il aurait il en
reste
encore une fois qui a fuit encore la
moitié de la population
donc si d'un point de vue russe ça leur
permet de dire vous voyez on fait
attention civile est par ailleurs c'est
l'heure ensuite ils peuvent dire si
philippe frappe scellant pas me dire
mais écoutez il ya plus de civils donc
on peut frapper où c'était une
rhétorique on entendait beaucoup en
syrie
c'est à dire il ya eu des conflits et
des des couloirs humanitaires
bon bah s'il ya des civils qui sont pas
partis c'est donc que ce sont des
terroristes et il voulait rester voilà
donc il ya
ça devient aussi un enjeu diplomatique
et après faut pas oublier l'objectif
humanitaire vraiment l'enjeu principal
c'est de protéger les civils est par
ailleurs aussi mais c'est un enjeu
diplomatique
tout faire pour que kiev kharkiv au
dessin etc ne soit pas rasé comme grozny
en tchétchénie en 1999
la vérité effectivement justement cessé
ses négociations il ya plusieurs
rencontres depuis le début de ce conflit
est ce que c'est un espoir est ce qu'on
peut en attendre quelque chose
rapidement
j'en peut que le souhaiter que l'année
que la diplomatie
prennent le pas fresnes prennent le pas
en tout cas avant de conserve avec les
opérations militaires
pour donner le encore une fois le
contexte au début assez rapidement dans
le conflit il ya eu des des
négociations qui ont été entamées à la
frontière entre la biélorussie et
l'ukraine
mais c'était un niveau infra ministériel
gtd des ambassadeurs c'était des
conseillers des
là ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'ils
hier en même temps que le sommet des
chefs d'état et du gouvernement
européens à versailles en même temps il
y avait pour la première fois le
ministre étrangère russe et son
homologue ukrainien qui se sont
rencontrés en turquie on va dire sous la
médiation la ministre des affaires
étrangères turc
puisque la la la turquie depuis des
années donc plein de
conflit où elle est en
ou la russie et est parti souvent il ya
comme c'est un jeu de médiation prend
l'avion syrie havrais en séries en
arménie on l'a vu en libye etc
alors ce qui est intéressant c'est que
ça n'a rien donné hier que tu as été
plutôt négative chacun est resté sur sa
position et notamment il n'y a pas eu
d'avancée
sur l'océan cessez le feu qui à court
terme et évidemment ce qu'on pouvait
espérer
le plus néanmoins ya des signes des
signaux faibles
du fait que malgré tout la diplomatie
avance un peu après l'avancée dans quel
sens ça va dépendre aussi du rapport de
force militaire
mais alors les signaux faibles sont les
suivants ils sont notamment du côté
ukrainien ce qui est logique puisque
c'est comme les ukrainiens
sur lesquels s'exerce un rapport de
force mystérieuse
zelensky a dit qu'il était il ya
commencé à sous-entendre sur la chaîne
nbc américaine qu'il était ouvert
à une neutralisation diplomatique de la
pologne de la que la de l'ukraine que
l'ukraine ne fasse plus partie de l'otan
c'est qu'aujourd'hui l'objectif des
décisions à l'otan soit l'otan et dans
la constitution ukrainienne visiblement
sur la question du don basse sur le
l'autonomie du nom basse voire plus il
est prêt
avant si certains diplomates ont six
teams et qu' il pourrait y avoir
forme d'accord sur la crimée qui de
facto est un endroit mais de facto elle
est heureuse depuis 2014 donc là on voit
des avancées du côté russe
on voit des ce qui peut parler d'une
hypocrisie terrible mais mes démos qui
pourrait servir de base de négociation
ils ont déclaré qu'ils voulaient pas
renverser le gouvernement de l inss qui
finance l'opération militaire spéciale
comme ils disent et ressemble beaucoup à
une tentative de
décapitation du gouvernement fin ils ont
dit il ils ont dit que non
donc voit et ça va dépendre de la
situation militaire sur le terrain
il ya un concept de clausewitz capelle
les points culminants donc on fait les
serres qu'il arrive à un moment dans un
conflit où le le rapport de force se
stabilise c'est à dire que le celui qui
avance n'a plus intérêt à avancer que
s'il avance trop il y perdra tous
derrière absolument et donc à
la question c'est à partir de quand le
point culminant va être atteint est-ce
qu'on est au début de cela et par
ailleurs ou est ce point culminant on a
vu pendant que le point culminant ça
n'est pas aujourd'hui
le
la prise de contrôle totale du pays par
la russie
alors mais où est ouverte le point
culminant
quand ça va être exigeant il et les
négociations diplomatiques vont vont
aussi dépendre de ça il ya aussi un
risque c'est quelqu'un en variant les
commentaires je crois que c'est valve
peso tout à l'heure qui est qui en
parlait sur l'extension du conflit où
est-ce que poutine peut-il s'arrêter on
pense notamment la moldavie alors on va
peut-être le montrer sur la carte qui
est libre mais la moldavie c'est ce
territoire c'est ce pays qui est ici et
à côté il ya la donc la moldavie c'est
ce pays là et le long il ya la
transnistrie la transnistrie qui est
déjà sous contrôle russe oui alors un
tout petit peu d'histoire donc la
moldavie en 91 avec la chute de lui
refaire devient indépendante est en fait
cette toute petite bande de terre qu'ils
avaient la transnistrie des 80 non
c'était un territoire russophone des 91
ils déclarent leur indépendance qui n'a
jamais été reconnu officiellement est
les russes pour acter cette indépendance
de fait déploie des soldats russes
depuis en transnistrie bihouix est très
ancien il ya environ dix mille à deux
mille soldats russes en transnistrie
et ce qui s'est passé en deux une chose
assez intéressante c'est que je pas si
vous vous souvenez mais le lukashenko le
président biélorusse dictateur
biélorusse un moment à la télévision
publique avait montré une carte de
l'invasion russe et notamment des
objectifs et des plans enfin le plan
complet et ska est étonnant c'est qu'ils
avaient tout cas non ça c'est logique
mais y avait une flèche qui partait de
la crimée qui allait vers l'ouest vers
véro des sas en a parlé tout à l'heure
mais si on la carte montrait par
loukachenko et bien cette offensive la
flash elle déborde sur la transnistrie
mais sauf qu officiellement la
transnistrie c'est toujours me le dit
auxerre caen fait si si demain les
russes arrivent à faire la jointure avec
le dessin ils sont en contact direct
avec la transnistrie qui peuvent s qui y
vont aller au delà et alors là on peut
avoir une crainte légitime c'est qu'en
fait la moldavie qui en plus est le pays
des pays qui reçoit le plus de réfugiés
d'ukrainiens
il ya quelques jours a officiellement
demandé
son adhésion
à l'union européenne alors c'est un
processus très long elle ne pourrait
rentrer dans l'union européenne que dans
dix ans mais elle a déposé sa fiche de
candidature et le jour d'après les
tiraspol donc c'est là entre guillemets
capitale de la transnistrie a fait une
annonce officielle en disant écoutez
maintenant puisque c'est comme ça on va
demander ils ont dit pacifiquement mais
on va demander à ce que notre
indépendance soit reconnue
internationalement endroit donc on voit
qu'il ya un nouveau front qui pour
l'instant n'est pas militaire reste en
politique mais qui s'ouvre sur cette
question alors la question de la
transnistrie qui est regardé de partout
les experts depuis des années comme un
point chaud
potentiel la question c'est ce que
maintenant le conflit va s'élargir
sachant que la moldavie n'est n'est pas
dans l'otan donc si ça s'étend des
le conflit s'étende et en moldavie le
temps ne réagirait pas comme il n'a pas
réagi a pesé mais en tout cas on n'est
pas dans une logique d'escaladé comme
comme si je sais pas à quelque chose de
aujourd'hui complètement impensable les
rues sont très en pologne où voilà donc
effectivement centres extra c'est
différent merci beaucoup alexis d'avoir
une fille avec nous aujourd'hui merci à
vous d'avoir été très nombreux merci au
service infographie et bien sûr mais
tous les jours les l'éclairage qui dit
kiki nouvelle carte à jour effectivement
comme vous pouvez le voir et vous pouvez
d'ailleurs retrouver ces cartes qui sont
accusés plusieurs fois par jour sur le
site du figaro merci en tout cas d'avoir
bien sûr d'avoir suivi ce live peut-être
prendre une toute petite dernière
question qui dit que l'effondrement de
l'armée ukrainienne n'est plus qu'une
question de jours les russes cantons des
villes il faut un blocus de 7,6 le
conflit peut durer quand même plusieurs
mois comme on l'a dit oui je ne sais
encore une fois dans cette guerre il
faut utiliser le conditionnel il faut
être très prudent
la guerre est imprévisible voilà donc
tous enfin toutes les
c'est une possibilité mais le l'affirmer
de manière catégorique certainement pas
très bien merci alexis une nouvelle fois
merci à vous d'avoir été nombreux merci
au service infographie et je vous dis à
bientôt pour de nouveaux lives sur
figaro l'est